hi I'm Erik Bosse and Jurassic world
falling Kingdom is the latest dinosaur
movie to join a cinematic universe full
of history that no one ever learns from
because it's more fun that way
let's rewatch fallen kingdom's
scene-by-scene and point out all the
details that you might've missed Easter
eggs that connected this successors DNA
to the pasture assic history and the
subtle cinematic choices that make this
offspring special because as mr. DNA
would tell us it takes a mix of ancient
mosquitoes and frogs to get that Dino
DNA yeah I kind of forced it spoiler
warning if you haven't seen fallen
kingdom yet and let's get started this
sequels fun opening sequence shows a
recovery team in the park ruins on isla
Nublar a submarine finds the remains of
the indominus rex which was dragged
underwater by the massive Mosasaurus at
the end of the previous film later mills
scientists will use DNA from this bone
to create a new species the endo Raptor
pollen kingdom was directed by day a
Bayona
a filmmaker known for a really good eye
with horror imagery and the use of
shadows for movies like the orphanage
and right away in this scene he teases a
visual device that he uses throughout
the movie flash illumination of a murky
background to reveal the threat as the
camera follows the tracker up to the
surface lightly illuminates the
silhouette of the Mosasaurus overhead
Bayona does this same trick moments
later when the subs headlight switch off
and the Moses sources outline appears
behind them he also does it on the
surface with the t-rex who is hidden in
the background behind the tech guy and
only illuminated briefly when flashes of
lightning light him up and by the way
notice how this tech is wearing a yellow
rain jacket that is a direct nod to the
jacket worn by Dennis Nedry in his death
scene the original drastic park this
guy's death gives us a visual callback
of a different kind opening this movie
with the image of the mosasaurs leaping
out of the water to chomp on his dinner
this echoes the early shot a Jurassic
world where that Dino eats the great
white shark premiere we move on to this
news footage explaining the volcanic
activity of Isla Nublar and the
political debate over whether to save
the dinosaurs if you look closely at the
headline ticker
you can see one headline that says US
president questions existence of
dinosaurs in the first place and this
feels like a nod to the current US
president who tends to deny basic
reality there's a similar nod later in
the movie that I will get to and then
after this is a cameo by dr. Ian Malcolm
Jeff Goldblum urging the Senate to let
the Dinos die he warns about man
cataclysmic changes like death saying
quote you don't know what it looks like
until you're standing at the gates now
Malcolm is metaphorically referring to
the gates of the afterlife like the
pearly ones are the ones upheld but he
also could be nodding to the literal
gates of Jurassic Park a passage that
had indefinitely marked an entry to help
for him then we jump to Claire Dearing
bryce dallas howard our first shot of
her is this close above her heels and
this is a sly reference to the close-ups
of her running in heels in Jurassic
world which ya remember had a lot of
people talking also the coffee she's
holding is from the brand caveman coffee
you can see that CC logo there that
company was co-founded by Tate Fletcher
who did stop work on Jurassic world as
an engine soldier in the office Claire
talks on the phone to congresswoman
Delgado about dinosaur conservation now
the name Delgado sounds a lot like a
reference to Richard Delgado he was an
artist who did concept art for pasture
ESIC Park movies Claire then whisks off
to the estates of Benjamin Lockwood
played by James Cromwell Lockwood is the
former partner to John Hammond whose
portrait Claire looks at Lockwood
possesses a cane topped with an amber
just like his partner Hammond did she
also meets with Eli Mills now notice the
portrait that he passes that is of
author Mary Shelley she wrote the novel
Frankenstein which has the same warning
against plain god that the Jurassic
series does so basically this is
Frankenstein's author presiding over a
lab that Frankenstein's extinct species
into new uncontrollable monsters clever
girl as Lockwood bemoans is falling out
with Hammond notice this shot of his
granddaughter well kind of Maisie
the director uses some more like
trickery here basking Maisie and a
powerful beam of sunlight
he's literally highlighting the girl to
foreshadow her significance revealed
later on the end of the movie we learned
that she's actually a clone of
Lockwood's daughter and that human
experimentation is what drove the two
partners apart so as Lockwood hints at
his backstory
the director is spotlighting the true
cloned elephant in the room
Claire recruits Owen Grady Chris Pratt
so that they'll have a better chance of
getting the Raptor blue and then the two
of them along with Claire's assistant
Xia and Franklin head to the island
there they meet Wheatley who leads the
rescue operation he's played by Ted
Levine perhaps best known for playing
Buffalo Bill in the Silence of the Lambs
Levine is a perfect casting choice here
Wheatley is a trophy hunter he
statistically pulls teeth out of the
dinosaurs that he catches for
collection similarly Buffalo Bill was a
serial killer who skinned his victims to
make his skin suit the expedition on
islands and the ruins of the part
produce a lot of callbacks and parallels
to the past Jurassic films the team is
greeted by a massive grazing
Brachiosaurus giving them the same sense
of awe that the characters in the first
movie did and this callback is
underlined by the music here the score
in this moment mixes in John Williams is
iconic Jurassic Park theme reminding us
of that memorable swell in the first
film also during the scene you can make
out a faded sign for Margaritaville
that's calling back the restaurant in
the parks main thoroughfare in Jurassic
world along with that movies cameo with
Jimmy Buffett himself oh and search for
blue leads to this flips truck with the
old school 90s make now it's looking at
the base of this large tree suggesting
this could be the same truck that grant
Tim and Lexy were in in the original
Jurassic Park there's also a close-up of
the truck sideview mirror with the words
objects in mirror larger than they
appear
that's a callback to Spielberg's
memorable close-up from the chase scene
in the original movie during the
volcanic eruption Clair and Franklin are
attacked by a Baryonyx that dinosaurs
existence was hinted at in the first
movie it only appeared as a reflection
and on the park map the eruption leads
to this massive Stampede with Owen Clair
and Franklin taking cover behind a
fallen tree just like Grant and the kids
did during the Gallimimus Stampede in
the original movie at the gyrosphere the
Train asaurus rex appears with a
last-minute save and a triumph with roar
echoing the last scene of Jurassic Park
and if you look closely you can see that
this t-rex still has the battle scars
from her fight with the Raptors in the
movie and the into source Rex and recive
world they survived an intense
gyrosphere sinking sequence and barely
make it on the departing barge turning
back to see this saddest dinosaur in the
world left behind on the dock as the ash
overtakes his dinosaur notice how it
rears on its hind legs once more
reminding us of its introduction
[Music]
jeez that music really undercuts any
emotional moment doesn't it moving on
Wheatley makes Xia operate on blues
wounds and under his breath he calls her
a nasty one now that's another political
now that I'm sure won't divide anyone
but what we want to do is to replenish
this such a nasty rust and in order to
save blue they need a blood transfusion
from the sedated t-rex a scene that
Bayona actually provided a commentary
for he said that he pitched this scene
to Steven Spielberg himself to try to
have another moment of tension during
this transitional section of the movie
and he loved the idea of giving the
actors a practical effect to work off of
and he said it was Chris Pratt's idea
for Owen to dive through the t-rex is
open mouth right before it snaps shut
and we get another nod to the original
movie here when Owen sees the t-rex is I
am closed notice how her pupil changes
size just like it did when Lexi pointed
the flashlight at it during the surgery
on blue Owen flashes back to his
memories training the dinosaur as a baby
this is intercut with Maisie back in
Lockwood's mansion watching recordings
of these training sessions on the
computer and notice how Maisie is now
wearing a red hoodie which he actually
wears throughout the rest of the movie
Bayona said that this was a nod to
Elliot in et now falling kingdom was
produced by Spielberg's production
company Amblin entertainment and Bayona
included a few super galoshes that we'll
get to later Maisy overhears a debate
between Mills and Henry Wu bebe Wong's
character making a return from Jurassic
world and the original Jurassic Park
Henry Wu's name's also appeared on the
news report headline ticker earlier on
and as Maisie backs away and hiding she
gets her first encounter with the Indo
Raptor in the cage behind her as claw
reaches out and try to grab her and this
movie may be the first Jurassic movie to
depict a dinosaur's upper claw and such
a slow creepy almost supernatural type
threat actually Bayona said that he
based this gesture on the movie
Nosferatu that was the classic vampire
film of 1922 in which Count Orlok had
similar clawing fingers in a crypt at a
similar hunting pace like the Indo
Raptor does here as the dinosaurs are
brought into Lockwood's estate the t-rex
is given a goat to eat this is a
callback to the original Jurassic Park
goat as well as the poor goat and
Triassic world and during the auction
mayhem notice how the elevator keypad
code is 7 3 3 7
that's a nod to a short film by Sergio G
Sanchez who helped Leona get his start
as a filmmaker Sanchez wrote the script
for the orphanage which by owner
director
as the Indo Raptor tears through the
mansion oh and Claire and Macey see the
soldier get dragged behind the exhibit
this is a visual callback to the very
first death of this whole franchise the
park worker whom the Raptor drags into
the cage as the interrupter stalks Mazie
into her bedroom its claw taps on the
floor
the Raptors claws do this same creepy
gesture in the kitchen scene in the
first Jurassic Park which actually this
whole scene is designed to invoke you
also see this with the shot of the Indo
Raptors shadow on the wall behind it
which is a recreation the Raptor shadow
on the wall behind Tim when the kids
scarfed down jello Bayona also meant for
this scene to evoke another vampire
movie Dracula from 1979 the movies flesh
of my flesh scene features some similar
shots with the threat coming in through
the window as the girl lies in bed also
if you look closely in Maisy's bedroom
Bayona snuck in another Spielberg Amblin
referenced a little 80 figurine sitting
on the shelf and of course with blues
help the humans are able to kill the
Indo Raptor epically impaling it on the
horns of the Triceratops skull very cool
this is a nifty illustration of the
movies science versus nature theme the
indoor Raptor is more a product of
science at this point a freak experiment
and the thing that brings it down is a
dinosaur in its most natural state
a true fossil from the ancient world and
after they release the imprisoned
dinosaurs into the human world this
movie's final sequence brings back in
Malcolm during his voice of a warning
phaona includes a shot of pterodactyls
flying in the sunset it's a callback to
the final shot of the pelicans in
Jurassic Park and the final shot of
Jurassic Park 3 and the pterodactyls in
empathy and that brings us to the final
spoken line of the movie from dr.
Malcolm welcome to Jurassic world now of
course this line is yet another nod to
the first movie when dr. Hammond first
welcomed us to a world where humans and
dinosaurs coexist welcome to Jurassic
and by the way there was a post-credits
scene at the end of its movie showing
pterodactyls roost atop the fake eiffel
tower at the paris las vegas casino
careful with those bets fellas in Vegas
it's really easy to spare no expense a
question for you guys since fallen
Kingdom made us feel surprise amount of
feels for the dinos which dinosaur did
you feel the worst for blue the Raptor
sad little foot comment down below or
tweet me directly at a box and following
her Ark stars on Twitter for updates on
our videos like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rock stars
for deep dives into movies you love we
got breakdowns at Marvel and Star Wars
and Pixar and an in-depth review of
fallen Kingdom that you should look at
and if you're curious about the Dino I
felt the worst for obviously that little
thing I mean I just know how he feels
I've been left behind on many Docs while
my friends go out boating I think
they're just jealous of my shirts I say
what you want but flamingos used to be
dinosaurs dumb dumb bye Wow Wow
don't make fun of my shirt